after four long tense days we've reached
a historic moment in this election we
can now project the winner
of the presidential race
victory after the long wait cnn projects
joseph r biden jr is elected the 46th
president of the united states
former vice president joe biden will win
pennsylvania
and nevada putting him over the 270
electoral votes he needs to become the
46th
president of the united states it is a
story of incredible political
perseverance
joe biden making it to the highest
office in the land
on his third attempt with a running mate
that will become america's first female
and first black
vice president we did it we did it joe
you're gonna be the next president of
the united states
a liberal washington that rejected
donald trump from the start
were at the finish line elated
[Applause]
but this was much bigger than their
corner
it was a day that saw a country erupt in
emotion
i feel happy overjoyed
jubilant free excited
i feel just i'm so happy i'm feeling
very confident that joe biden's going to
be an awesome president and
going to address all of the issues that
trump's been ignoring and being divisive
about
people here feel jubilant vindicated
that their voices
are finally going to be heard and that
this is the dawn of a new era
in america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a healing moment for millions of
americans
well it's easier to be a parent this
morning it's easier to be a dad
it's easier it's easier to tell your
kids
character matters it matters telling the
truth matters
being a good person matters
the president learned he'd hit the rough
whilst out playing golf
his first outing after spending four
days
in a political bunker
i love you he left with a signature
thumbs up
after days of brash defiance and
threatening a flurry
of legal action
democrats didn't score the landslide
they wanted
but they believe they have secured a
seismic system
america's dark night is over
[Applause]
biden's political life started 48 years
ago today in the senate
he became known as amtrak joe famed for
his commute on the train from delaware
and a preference for consensus over
conflict
i am pleased to award our nation's
highest civilian honor
the presidential medal of freedom
in barack obama he enjoyed a political
renaissance as vice president
in this year of racial unrest and a
raging pandemic
the man met the moment helped by an
unlikely alliance of women people of
color
old and young voters promising all
stability
we have to put the anger and the
demonization behind us
it's time for us to come together as a
nation to heal
it's not going to be easy we have to try
good night joe biden knows he faces a
country divided
an opponent who built support despite
his loss
finding common ground will be his
greatest ever test
cordelia lynch sky news washington